While some plants specialized in repulsing animals,...
...many others needed their collaboration and touch...
...to be able to conquer faraway territories,...
...to grow in new places.
Seeds do not move by themselves,...
...but an animal can turn into a transport vehicle for a small seed.
In 1948, the Swiss engineer Georges de Mestral noticed this fact.
After his peaceful walks with his dog in the countryside,...
...he was fascinated by the strength that certain seeds use...
...to attach themselves to his clothes, or to his four-legged friend's fur.
In summertime, after a walk in the countryside,...
...he always had to spend time removing an incredible variety of seeds from his socks and clothes.
His curiosity took the engineer to study in detail...
...the device by which these clandestine voyagers attach themselves...
...through dozens of hooks to clothes.
Thanks to this research, Mestral designed a well-known attachment system called Velcro.